E
TAKEN FROM TOOME OF THE CLD
RUSSIA CONTROLLED
REPORTINN  FNIGHT THERE NDOINIAT
VLIR IED FOR CHILDREN MARIA LOVY
ORDEAL WITH CNN'S NICK PATONHILG
WALSH. HERE'S AMAY BE FREE, BT'S
HAUN WHEN YEAR IT WAS
ST ACROSS THE RIVER WHERE
THURSDAYSHELLING KILLING A LALD
CHILD HNT TMECOMINGE  13. FIRSTA
CHARHA LED
AGAST B AND
I OFF, SO
B AND SHELLING WATER
LICE WON'T LETID. CHGEIS FIRST E
GOT BAC WHESOMECE CRENDIZZA IST
GREAT. VIOLENT R THE
NIGHT LEFT GLASS BKE U BANGSRDER
SURE YESTERDAY. THE WOODS VOTEAW
OUTIMEA HAD GENTLETION DAILY RUO
SOLUTIONS. THANKIL. IT
S REAL STUDIO JUST UM WHATT VEOD
FROM NEIGHBORS EVER SINCE SHEEHD
LET WHAT SHE
THOUGHT. BE A SA
TO CRISEKS. DOLLARWNITIMATE. HOA
SEPARATE, AND SHME
T
ALN THE SHS
THEYOT FOODECAUSE H
FATHER HAST JOB IN THER. IS
WHO LET THEIR
THEULD WITH CAUTION AS
SYMPATHIZERS REALLY SHORT. HMM
THAT'S NICE.H I ASK
. KE YST BETWE TWO SID OHE NICKS
ADAPTING TO LIFE IN HER SON NOWL
CISTOTF RETURN TO A
COUNTRY WHE THEIR FAMIE ARE
THE KIND OF HOME M PARENTS
LIKE TO DO, BUT ALSO
AROUND THAT THERE A
LIFE IN R. YOUTIALLY IN
INCIDENTS IN WHICH WES TYE
DEMANDINGOUTS THAT THEY
HOHE UKRAINIAN GOVERGIVE THEM MA
IATED WITH THE
RUCTION OF THEIR HOMES AND
ALSO TWOHR THE DING CONSTANT INL
EXACTLY OS LANDING
. TH BK
DRUMBEAT OF
IFEFAOM ANYTHING ANY CHILD WANTO
COME BACK TO. IT'SNG,SE A LOT OE
SEND THEHINOW TO THEPARENT WFERO
AREAS OF UKRAINES INGVOLUNTARY,E
FROM COMPLATED CIRAT WH S
FACING AT THA THEY
COUPLE OFCONTROLLED BY RUSSIANSS
PARENT. THEPARATEDRO